I paid for everything in my first couple
relationships it didn't bother me that
they didn't really I mean I think now I
have a little more perspective and I see
how messed up that is why do you think
it's messed up I mean dinner really like
can't buy dinner oh it's not you chose
to it's that they couldn't no it's not
that they even couldn't they did they
did it was a high performing woman with
more disposable income than many of the
men that you're dating that's a
difficult one as well because there is
some data to suggest that if you are in
a relationship where the woman is the
primary Breadwinner there's a two times
increase risk of divorce there is a 50
increased risk of the men having to use
erectile dysfunction medication there is
self-reports of lower sexual
satisfaction from women there is
self-reports of lower levels of orgasm
during sex from those same women again
all of this is on average there are like
tons and tons and tons of people that
break this rule the point is you as a
high performing woman have the tall girl
problem